well the Democratic stronghold of San
Francisco has become well especially in
downtown a festering pile of garbage
feces and drug needles according to a
survey by a local news station Bay
Area's NBC's investigation of 153 city
blocks including popular tourist spots
found trash on every block 300 piles of
feces on ninety six blocks lovely 100
discarded hypodermic needles on forty
one blocks that's all so this is a
sanctuary city is it well here's a local
deli owner he's fed up it's it's filthy
it's disgusting
yesterday we taped somebody just on the
side of my building peeing on my
restaurant in broad daylight I actually
have pictures of people shooting up in
the street it's absolute mayhem at this
point it's completely out of control I
don't call her my radio show today San
Francisco recently with her kids and she
also saw someone shooting up right on
the side of the street I'm tying up the
arm and putting the needle and had to
shield her daughter's eyes not exactly a
paradise for businesses or workers
joining us now in San Francisco San
Francisco Republican Party Vice Chair
Ken Lu is also a commissioner with the
BART police citizen Review Board and
Ethan Berman a political commentator in
Bay Area radio host now Ethan I love San
Francisco let me just say I love it
I family there I have friends there been
going for a long time it has a major
problem and I don't care if you're
Democrat Republican or somewhere in
between it's not getting better it seems
to be getting worse what do you think
well I mean it's true it is problematic
I will say that under Mayor Ed Lee who
recently passed away that we've reduced
the number of veterans who are homeless
in the city of San Francisco we are
taking an approach but remember we are
being handcuffed by a number of laws
that prohibit the ability of taking care
of people with mental health issues and
making them get the psychiatric care
that they need getting them the
addictive care we we allow people under
the guise
civil liberties to be free and not put
them in places to get the help that they
need to protect and help themselves let
alone others and allow them to become
contributing members of society again
this is a really big issue nobody wants
to step in feces I have children I don't
want to do that either
I don't like finding use needles but
there are approaches and the city is
trying but we actually need some federal
help in this case in my opinion because
a lot of the homeless are not from San
Francisco they come because they're not
going to freeze to death when we're
having a cold snap unlike the rest of
them are you blaming droppings are you
playing donald trump for the fact that
San Francisco this is it's excessive
yeah no absolutely not this is a
successive series of issues and count
rulings for that matter
Laurie you know about that we've had for
federal courts ruled that we can't do
certain things don't get me started on
the judge don't get me to the judges I'm
gonna do a whole big segment on the
judges tomorrow but let's go to you on
this this this is so sad on so many
levels but this is supposed to be the
progressive paradise of San Francisco
it's a super Democrat majority the Board
of Supervisors for years going back to
Gavin Newsom when he tried to get rid of
the cash for though remember the cash
for the homeless who want to do the
vouchers they fought fought him back
then that was he was my first guest by
the way on my radio show that I ever had
17 years ago was Gavin Newsom but to me
it's gotten worse and worse even with
some modest improvements around the
edges go ahead I think we're having
audio we're having audio problems I'm
happy to answer that
hi yeah sorry it's directly yeah no yes
absolutely it's directed to you can so
yeah yeah so San Francisco hasn't had a
Republican elected office for multiple
decades now and so none of the problems
that we can see in terms of the homeless
era can be attributed to the Republicans
at all in San Francisco simply because
we don't have a single Republican
elected to office representing San
Francisco the homeless epidemic that we
have right here is just getting worse in
fact every year I was born here in San
Francisco and I could see
progressively every year the problem has
been even worse and worse every year
with no solutions I've met with multiple
border supervisor numbers here in San
Francisco and they just keep asking for
more money and when they ask for more
money
it's basically rewarding a program that
doesn't have any benchmarks there is no
solution and their solution is to just
throw more money at the problem ken what
they're also doing is declaring
themselves per pet you know a year after
year where sanctuary City where a
sanctuary state will see the problem in
Orange County we see the problem in LA
we have tent cities in both places and
we're bringing more people into the into
the situation and more people who are
indigent and themselves are without jobs
and a way to support themselves so I
don't see how the sanctuary status of
San Francisco or the state is doing is
doing anybody any favors Ethan and Ken
great segment thank you so much is a lot
to get through on this and we're gonna
have to have the co-ops with some
creative solutions